- Today I'm going to be
reacting to some of the content
that's on my old phones.
I went and got a couple of them out.
One of them, I'm so upset,
I cannot for the life of
me remember the passcode.
I keep trying, but it says my phone is
disabled for 1,167 minutes.
These kind of feel like a time capsule.
It's like a portion of my life just frozen
in phone form.
A huge thank you to
LastPass for sponsoring
a portion of this video.
And this could not be a better video to
integrate LastPass into because,
one of the things, if you guys don't know,
I always have a lot of different phones.
They even have this great feature where
if you don't want to come up with a
new unique password,
they'll make one for you!
So with LastPass, it will remember
all of my passwords.
I'm able to quickly login to new phones,
and devices, and computers.
It works on IOS, Android, Windows, Mac.
I love LastPass,
I've been using it for
the past couple of years.
It's made it a lot
quicker and seamless when
I get a new phone to review.
I just login to LastPass
and I instantly have access
to all of my accounts.
So thank you LastPass
for sponsoring a portion of this video.
Now I cannot wait to get into seeing
what's on my old phones.
So these are the main phones
we're going to be checking out today.
This is the iPhone 6, which came out in
September of 2014.
It's been my dream to be first in line
for any Apple store event.
This is it, like, we're here,
we're first.
(crowd cheering)
This is the iPhone 6S
which came out in 2015.
It's the day of the iPhone 6S launch,
and puppy is not coming with us.
You don't want to come.
Well there's nobody else here, surprise.
The middle of nowhere in North Carolina.
First in line for the phone.
Is anybody here yet?
Open up, I'm ready.
One of the newest features
is the force touch,
so you'll be able to
"peek in" as they said.
They have definitely
seen some better days.
I almost always have
had cases on my phones.
So they're not in too bad of a condition.
So let's first boot up the iPhone 6
and see what's on it.
I did turn this on already,
and I didn't want to connect it to wifi
because I didn't want all
of these apps to update.
This is the first page of my iPhone 6.
The craziest part is seeing Vine on here.
So just going through I feel like
I have a lot of the same sort of apps.
It's just funny to see like the old logos,
because obviously in 2014,
a lot has changed since then.
I guess this would be the end of 2015 then
when I got rid of this phone
to upgrade to the iPhone 6S.
The Aging Booth.
The Ugly Booth.
I used to go to Hot 8 Yoga all the time.
Looks like I was still potentially,
maybe using Canon.
Ship, that was a really
great shipping app.
But they went under.
Clash of Clans,
oh my god I used to be obsessed.
What I really want to see though
is what are some of the old
photos that I have on my phone.
The last few photos that I have on here
are me buying this phone.
I was in North Carolina,
I remember I was on family vacation.
So there it is.
Me buying the new phone.
And there's my little Matty!
Oh my gosh,
he looks like such a rat dog.
This was us in the car on
the drive to North Carolina.
I was measuring Matty
to see what his size was
in relation to the Apple watch.
What a perfect doggy!
Here's Matty playing Nintendo.
(video playing)
(laughing)
He had such bad allergies.
He used to just like lick and itch.
Poor little buddy.
(dog barking)
That's Matty hiding under my drone.
So it looks like in 2015 I was using Sony,
but I was also still using Canon.
Little Matty the DJ!
He's perfect.
He's perfect!
I was making his meal.
Are you hungry?
(dog barks)
Oh my god!
Are you hungry?
He's so small.
I just can't believe all
these cute little pictures
of my dog.
(video playing)
One of the craziest things though,
is going back to this older phone.
Which is still a really good phone.
I know a lot of people
that still have iPhone 6's
as their main phone.
Like, it's running very well.
I kind of almost miss
this fingerprint reader.
It's just really, really nice.
I wonder what some of my last email was.
Doesn't look like
anything that interesting.
A bunch of spam.
I only have like three pages of apps.
What the heck?
What is Peach?
Well it's not loading.
I think it was another social network.
I don't know what happened to it.
Oh my gosh this is my old setup,
in the white room.
My office was so different then.
Oh my gosh!
It's me and Ro and Cookie!
Of course more Matty content.
What an angel.
What an angel!
Look at that little face!
Let's see what some of
the last things were
that Jenna and I were talking about.
How's Matty?
Do you need food?
I plan on coming back but
this vid took forever.
He is good.
We just napped.
Nothing at all has changed
in our conversations at all.
This is the original iPhone.
Look at this thing.
It's so beautiful.
This is the one that I bought on Ebay.
So this one actually does turn on.
If it is charged.
(music playing)
This looks pretty legit.
(upbeat music plays)
This over here is was my
original first iPhone.
I feel like this phone,
I've got a lot of history.
This was what like made
my first viral video.
You're beautiful,
and you're perfect.
Don't let anyone tell you that you're not.
And then I saw that I
did an iPhone original
versus iPhone 11 video.
It was really fun because we
went out and took some photos.
I'd say video but this
didn't shoot video yet.
So we basically just did
a photo comparison of
the original iPhone to the iPhone 11.
It was really pretty shocking how good
these photos still were,
considering how long ago
this phone was released.
2007.
Here it is.
The original iPhone with one page of apps.
(laughs) Let's take a little picture,
shall we?
What an incredible device.
Like, this changed everything.
This is another one that I got.
This one wasn't mine.
I did have this phone.
This is one that I did an
unboxing of on my channel.
Man, I wish that this
other phone would start up.
It's not letting me do anything.
iPhone is disabled.
Try again in 1,170 minutes.
Alright.
I guess I'll keep trying.
See you in five years.
Well thank you guys for
watching this video.
This was really fun,
just to go back and see
what apps were on my phone.
And also I'm so happy that
I found this one phone,
because I never had my stuff
backed up to the cloud back then.
If you guys have a dog,
or a pet,
then you totally get it.
Anyway,
thank you again for watching.
If you guys like this video
make sure you give it a thumbs up.
Be sure to subscribe
for more of my videos.
Ane let me know if there's anything else
you guys would like to see me make
here on my channel.
I will see you guys in the next video.
Bye.
(closing music)